hey guys it's pete peppers and this is a
candy crush saga level 485 commentary
walkthrough with some tips added this is
I guess the toughest sort of his level
that came out in the last episode and I
think what makes it tough is that it's
you know most people don't really
understand how the chain reactions and
things work yet and there's just a
really small space on this one so it's
hard to get them going so I went back
and plated today it took me a few tries
and I learned some new things and I'm
going to explain to you how I got the
all three bottle caps in the 40 moves
that we have so I roll it here so the
real basic stuff about how these fizzes
work is in my other video that I thought
I made yesterday to explain this and
i'll put a link to that at the end but
um right now all we're doing is we do
want to clear the honey but it's not as
simple as saying okay we'll just clear
the honey first because there's a lot of
colors here and it makes it hard so what
I'm doing is I'm just looking for kind
of the best possible match I can get
that ol you know crack honey but also
sort of grow my thing I'm going to pause
it here for a second so right now when
we look over the board we have a yellow
that's got for phys and a norms this got
for phys and those are both ready that
you know once we match them again
they're going to spread they're going to
pop and spread the fizz to the other
ones of that same color now there's not
enough on the board where you know it's
going to start a chain reaction because
we got to in their different colors so
what we want to do is we want to look
for chances to make combos or just
specials in general because that'll
spread the phys two different colors a
little bit quicker so let me go ahead
and start it back up so I make it I make
a rap candy it explodes and it spreads
it to the yellow but then you can see it
also
sets off the other ones that are nearby
and I think you know in the times that I
played it just now I think that that's
probably essential for this board
anyways because you just don't have
enough room to move around so now we
start from the beginning we got a couple
little fizzes here making the green to
make a striped obviously it's going to
also grow the blue so that's cool the
fish plus the straight combo isn't as
good as the other ones just because
either one's going to spread the fizz on
their own I go ahead and do it here but
um you know it'd be just as good to do
it the other way too now I do like the
striped and especially the stripe that's
ready to pop and one of it what I did
instead of just trying to set it off is
um I tried to bring things down and
spread a little more fizz and I kind of
screwed up I guess you could say because
I didn't get a chance to set it off yet
but it's still sitting there waiting and
setting off that wrapped as it was good
because even if this doesn't go to a
full chain reaction it's really going to
spread the fizz so now I got a lot of
candies with a lot of fizz and I could
cite the striped off right now but
instead i'm going to set up this one
first and then i think i like to match
the yellow here and again match the
yellow because like well that's what we
want to do is we want to get more with
like more that are getting ready to
explode so if I match the yellow again
that's going to spread that out and now
I can make a fish and shoot off the
stripe and kind of grow the launch at
the same time so that's going to go over
there and grow those ones and hopefully
we'll get a little bit of a little bit
of action in the Cascade that's another
thing you can't really play in the
Cascade um you probably noticed while
you've been playing that you know it's a
little little confusing because I'm we
we don't get it there but that's okay
now we'd really have a lot we had this
group on the left side of yellow that
have that are ready to go another yell
in the middle so really at this point if
we can just set off a yellow one we
should be probably pretty good because
we have four and we should get a little
bit more action in the process so what I
posit again like what i was saying
though is that in the game usually when
you match three colors to get three
candies together or more they disappear
from the board now this is more like
pepper panic where they actually stay so
if you when you match it you're going to
at least have one that's left behind so
um that makes a little bit confusing and
hard to set things up but just keep that
in mind and take your time and you
should be able to you know get over that
all right so now um you know we can
match this yellow we got a couple other
ones around it they're already exploded
to you so hopefully we're going to
cascade but um there were enough yellows
that I thought it was a good enough time
and as they grow that should get us all
six okay so you can see we didn't really
like focus on one thing or the other we
just sort of on with what we had and
right here we can set up a color bomb or
coloring candy by matching the blue so
that that you know we got this little
gap here with the other things I think
that's really important because now we
have a coloring bomb with a fizz on it
so because one of the problems here is
the colors i think that painting the
painting just any of the colors to green
is good enough because we only have nine
move so we don't wanna get too fancy so
now we have a lot of green on board and
not that many red so that makes it a
little bit easier for us to get things
going I like making the fish here it's
going to explode there was something you
know there was more than four phys up at
the top we can make the
fish again narrow explode so those are
things to think about and this is
probably yeah this is this is going to
go ahead and do it then so from playing
you know what I came up with is you know
it's it's more about taking your time
and just figuring out what the best
thing you can do it is right there and
just really pay attention to how the
chain reaction would go you know like if
you just if you're just doing one color
than blowing it up then working on a
different color on blowing it up it's
going to be harder to get an actual
chain reaction because you would need to
have several of those of that color that
are big and that takes a lot of moves to
do that so try to work in the specials
like I did and and look for combos and
things so that you can spread it quickly
and especially a rat you know they don't
for the very first one I use the rap
like when you use the wrapped it'll hit
it twice and it all advies twice
especially if you have a couple
different colors with big one sitting
there that'll really speed things up so
I know it's a little confusing like i
said i'll link the other video at the
top right here and you can go watch that
if you're still a little confused at how
the sort of his works i hope this helps
in general and i hope that you will like
the video and subscribe to my channel
because i'd like to see you again soon
thanks